- ROOMMATE MEETING.
ROOMMATE MEETING!
- GOGO, WHAT THE HELL?
I'VE GOT A HANGOVER!
- I DON'T GIVE A [bleep]
ABOUT YOUR HANGOVER,
OKAY, BRENDAN?
I WANT A ROOMMATE MEETING,
AND I WANT IT NOW!
OKAY.
NOW, SOMEBODY'S
BEEN TAKING [bleep]
OUT OF THE REFRIGERATOR
AND THROWING IT
ON THE GROUND,
AND IT'S PISSING ME OFF.
IS THIS ANOTHER ONE
OF YOUR STUPID PRANKS, JONALD?
- NO.
AND YOUR PRANKS ARE STUPID.
- IS IT YOU, MONDAY?
- WHAT?
[eerie music]
- I SAID,
SOMEBODY'S BEEN TAKING [bleep]
OUT OF THE FRIDGE
AND THROWING IT
ON THE [bleep] GROUND.
AND I WANT TO KNOW
WHO IT IS,
BECAUSE IT'S NOT FUNNY!
- WELL, WHAT I WANT TO KNOW IS,
WHO KEEPS PULLING THE SHEETS
OFF MY BED
AND HANGING THEM
FROM THE CEILING FAN AT NIGHT?
- WAS THAT YOU, MONDAY?
- WHAT?
- HAVE YOU BEEN TAKING
EVERYBODY'S SHEETS OFF THEM
IN THE NIGHT AND HANGING THEM
FROM THE CEILING FANS?
- WHAT? NO.
- WELL, CLEARLY,
SOMEONE'S BEEN DOING THAT!
[glass shatters]
- WHOA!
WHO DID THAT?
- YEAH! WHO THE [bleep]
JUST DID THAT?
- WHICH ONE OF YOU
JUST THREW THAT BOTTLE?
- WHAT ARE WE EVEN TALKING
ABOUT RIGHT NOW?
- DID YOU [bleep]ING THROW
THAT BOTTLE, JONALD?
- NO, GOGO!
[bleep] YOU!
I DIDN'T THROW IT!
- WELL, DID YOU [bleep]ING THROW
THAT BOTTLE, BRENDON?
- YEAH!
YOU WOULD DO THAT, BRENDON.
- DUDE, NO!
I DIDN'T THROW THE BOTTLE!
- WELL, SOMEBODY THREW
THAT [bleep]ING BOTTLE,
AND YOU'RE THE ONE WHO DREW
DICKS ON EVERYONE'S FOREHEAD!
- YEAH, YOU DID DO THAT!
- BUT DICKS ARE HILARIOUS,
THOUGH!
THIS IS JUST DESTRUCTIVE!
WHAT ABOUT YOU, MONDAY?
DID YOU THROW THAT BOTTLE?
[low growl]
- WHAT BOTTLE?
- THE [bleep]ING BOTTLE, DUDE!
IT JUST SMASHED
AGAINST THE WALL,
AND YOU EVEN SAID
SOME [bleep] ABOUT IT!
- WELL, I DIDN'T THROW
A BOTTLE.
- WELL, OBVIOUSLY,
IT WASN'T PING.
HE'S GOT THE BEST GRADES
IN THE HOUSE.
- [hisses]
- GOOD POINT, PING.
COME ON, GUYS, LET'S COOL IT
WITH THE PROFANITY.
YOU KNOW PING'S VERY RELIGIOUS.
- [growls]
[guys groaning]
- AW, PING!
- UGH!
- COME ON!